hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll we've all heard stories of
families living in small towns where the
children grow up and make different
decisions some of them want to go to the
big city and test their fortunes others
want to stay behind and live a
comfortable life within the traditions
where their family grew up this kind of
difference between moving to the city
and living out in the country or even
the suburbs is increasingly becoming a
major partisan divide both in the United
States and worldwide as will Wilkinson
puts it in a recent paper he wrote there
are no Republican cities anymore in the
United States Republicans live in
suburbs in the country Democrats live in
urban areas Wilkinson is a vice
president for Policy Research at the
Niskanen Center in Washington DC and
he's dug into this question in a paper
he wrote called the density divide her
B'nai zation polarization and populist
backlash it's not just that people who
go to the big cities become liberal and
people who stay in the country become
conservative there's interesting
cause-and-effect relationships what kind
of people move to the city what kind of
people leave the city and move to the
country what do changing demographics
immigration and birth rates and so forth
what effects do they have on how people
think about the world not just who they
vote for but their outlook on life for
their outlook on other countries their
outlook on the economy this difference
between city life and suburban and
country life is increasingly becoming
the important difference between
different kinds of people here and
elsewhere and so it's important to dig
into how that's happening and why it is
so let's go
[Music]
we'll Wilkinson welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me on Sean so
you've written you know quite a
wonderfully interesting research paper
about the density divide which I want to
focus on for the podcast but first just
to you know get our listeners oriented
as to where we are
why don't you say a little bit about who
you are what perspective you're coming
from and also I'll give you a chance to
plug the niskin Center which is a recent
new appear and appear on the scene great
well I am
well Wilkinson I am the vice president
for research at the Niskanen Center in
Washington DC you pronounced it
correctly
and finish it's a finish last name but
the guy we named it after a parent
pronounced into scannin so it's finished
so I do so I do learn a little bit yeah
yeah the old some of my best friends our
finish line and what we do at the
niskanen Center we're a think-tank
we focused mostly on climate and energy
immigration welfare and economic and
social policy as well as a you know a
few more areas regulation so forth and
we've been around about four years and
we started as a sort of moderate
libertarian institution most of the
senior staff at niskanen are expats from
the Cato Institute which we all left for
various reasons and we have over the
course of the last three years or so
been trying to find our niche and we've
become less and less ideological and
more and more pragmatic and just
consider ourselves a moderate think-tank
but we tend to have a a you know
free-market II sort of focus but not in
a sort of traditional right-of-center
way we are big fans of social insurance
and the welfare state and one of our
James is how capitalism and the welfare
state mesh well together but and so for
those who don't know the Cato Institute
is I take it slightly more
straightforwardly ideological in the
sense of being pro capitalism
libertarian kind of place yes it is it's
it's there's a you know it's got a very
Orthodox version of libertarianism that
people may be familiar with if they've
read Ayn Rand or Robert Nozick or Murray
Rothbard
you know it runs you know they're you
know there's some diversity in views at
the Cato Institute but it's a it's a
narrow band that's within a pretty
Orthodox libertarian perspective and a
lot of us you niskanen who used to work
there left for because we grew out of it
in one way or another started to see
that we were making certain errors one
of the nice things about arguing for a
living is that you end up encountering
people who are smarter than you yeah
hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo you know and you can
never accept that you lost an argument
you know in the moment you know but you
know afterwards when you're you know
opening the fridge to make a sandwich it
2:00 in the morning and you're thinking
about it and you're just like yeah
there's really something wrong with my
position as you try to work it out you
you you know you try to cover the chinks
in your armor you know you try to shore
up your position and your and in in by
the time you figure out how to like you
fortify your general position you find
that you've given up something that you
had been standing on before and as you
iterate that process you just actually
end up with a pretty comprehensively
different set of views over time but
because it seems gradual you don't
really notice it necessary yeah actually
I mean this is not what we're here to
talk about but I'm very happy to talk
about it cuz it's awesome
in you know there's a idea of a phase
transition in physics
which is very similar to this and I
thought I was always skeptical of things
like the backfire effect where you say
that you know you give someone a piece
of evidence against their position and
they hold their position more strongly
I'm sure that's true sometimes but
there's clearly a timescale
question here presumably when they do
those psychology tests they're asking
the question right away
and underneath the surface these little
thoughts and facts percolate and then a
long time later their can suddenly be
whoosh you're like oh crap I got to
change my mind about everything you
might even forget where the initial
impetus came from yes sometimes I you
know I I think the funny thing
psychologically is said I'll look I
don't know if it's the same for other
people I know I'm a little bit weird but
I I tend to initially resist the idea
that I have changed my mind what I have
and I think that has something to do
with with kind of holding your the
narrative around your self-identity
steady in a way and and so there's a
resistance even acknowledging that you
changed your mind you just kind of tend
to interpret it in terms of well you
know I didn't really change my mind so
much as I you know I changed the
emphasis on this point and you know the
view that I have now is just a better
way to articulate what I thought
although there's a lot of rationalizing
that goes around goes you know that goes
into you know telling yourself what you
think and and but after a while you
start to notice that actually no I I'm
I'm straightforwardly contradicting what
I used to say the very first episode of
the mindscape podcast was with Carol
Tavarez who wrote a wonderful book
called mistakes were made but not by me
all about how we rationalize every
single thing we do and you're right just
continuing our sense of identity is is a
big part of it so but anyway okay good
we could I think we can talk about this
for an hour but we have other things to
other fish to fry and so in this paper
you've written is actually let me let me
finish the thought of the Miss Canon
center because I think that a lot of
things we're going to end up saying are
going to seem to the outside observer
like slightly critic
of Republicans or of right-wing people
more generally but did have you been a
Republican most of your life is that a
fair statement
um it's fair to say that I've been on
the right most of my life because I have
been a professional libertarian for most
of my professional life you know I went
to grad school you know got some grad
degrees in philosophy I and out of that
I started working at the Cato Institute
I've also worked at a place called the
Marquita Center which is part of the
large network of organizations that are
run by the by the coax or by the Koch
now and the and so I voted for
Republicans before but you know in most
presidential elections I think I you
know when I was younger voted for
libertarians but you know I voted for
Mitt Romney on identity politics grounds
I'm I grew up a sort of Mormon and I was
like you know that's my people and and
I'm not I think I might have voted for
George W Bush Oh in the over gore I'm
not sure I don't I don't I honestly
don't remember I or I might have voted
for whoever the libertarian candidate
was I remember favoring george w bush
over over carry but i don't know who i
actually voted for it might have been a
libertarian but yeah i so my most of my
professional life I've been in some way
a part of the right um and the
libertarian movement as part of this
right-of-center coalition that was
initially forged around anti-communism
and libertarians were always the the
socially liberal part the the most
socially liberal part of the right
coalition
I mean tend to be in favor of drug
legalization and decriminalization
decriminalization of sex work and to be
anti-war so there's a lot of
commonalities with P
on the left in fact that's one of the
reasons why I end up leaving the cato
institute is that my colleague brink
Lindsay and I had you know both decided
that we were tired of what you know what
people call right fusion ISM and the
kind of fusion of social conservatism
and more libertarian economic views and
at the Cato Institute as libertarians we
would often say that we have just as
much in common with people on the left
is on the right
but institutionally in just as a matter
of the practical political reality
you're hanging out with Republicans yeah
and those are the people you're helping
and and so we're like well let's make
good on this thing that we say and so we
had a project we were reaching out to
people who worked at think tanks on the
left to Center left-leaning magazines
and you know journals of ideas and we're
building a kind of left fusionist sort
of libertarianism that for a while we
called liberal terian ism which is a
terrible name I remember those days yes
I was paying attention to that and that
was going okay and then the Tea Party
came along and a lot of people at the
Cato honest you got super excited about
it and thought it was the kind of the
president at Cato at the time had sort
of believed that there was something
essentially libertarian in American in
the American political culture and that
this you know strand of our cultural DNA
which someday you know rise up and
there'd be this great efflorescence of
you know
populist libertarianism and he thought
the Tea Party was his moment and and and
and the stuff that brink and I was
saying was was a bit critical of the Tea
Party and all of a sudden our
concentration on building this coalition
with Democrats seemed counterproductive
and so we kind of had a a bit of tension
and a parting of the ways over that but
uh but but for the most part but you
know I
I've seen myself as part of the right
and what we do at the Miss Ghana center
mostly and though it's not publicly
visible as we go down on the hill we
work with moderate Republicans on our
issue priorities and the Trump
presidency has been a horror show for us
because our main goals are things like
getting Republicans to support a carbon
tax getting you know something like
comprehensive immigration reform past
things like that and then Trump has not
been very friendly to those efforts in
the Republican Party under Trump has
been friendly to those efforts but that
is where most of our our time goes that
we you know we had and this I guess gets
to my the the the the point of my paper
the genesis of my paper I we like most
everyone had expected Hillary Clinton to
win the election and we thought that our
and a comparative advantage was going to
be bringing along some moderate
Republican votes to support things like
legislation on climate change
comprehensive immigration reform and
things like that and because there's
going to need some Republican votes to
get through we were building the kind of
network of allies on the hill that would
be able to make that happen and then
Trump won the election and we were like
oh no and like a lot of people I was
like what the heck happened you know or
like what you know something's
something's gone screwy or we're missing
something and in you know at this you
know just a bit before that there had
been the big brexit vote and the UK and
you're starting to see these uprisings
of the populous right in Europe and
elsewhere and it seemed like a general
thing that was going on in the
explanations that I was hearing in to
account for it weren't that satisfying
to me you know like it's a bad
clash to do liberalism or it's a
backlash to political correctness or
demographic change in immigration you
know there was a lot in all of those
things that have you know make some
sense but it seemed somehow bigger than
that and more general so I started
digging into the kind of white rump
question and the and you know with an
orientation trying to understand where
kind of right-leaning populism was
coming from
why nationalism was all of a sudden a
thing again you know like it turns out
that history didn't end
okay so like what's what's what's
happening now and so the genesis of this
paper was trying to understand basically
why Trump won the election but also
white brakes it was happening why
populist nationalist parties keep
winning more and more votes share in
even the most liberal European countries
and and I hit on a couple of things that
I thought had been overlooked so I dug
into them it's especially interesting to
me because I'm finding this you know a
year plus into the podcast that certain
themes keep reappearing even though I
talked to very different people about
very different things so the idea of
cities and urbanization as a major
driver of the future of the world is
absolutely one of them I talked with
Jeffery West who talked about how
innovation and creativity are driven by
high density populations and I talked to
Joe walleston about how there's this
optimistic future where we can save the
planet by getting everyone into cities
and you know preserving the environment
outside and now you're saying that in
some sense major political trends
worldwide and in the United States
especially have a lot to do with
urbanization as a phenomenon yeah that's
right so the the thing that really got
me started is you know after 20
sixteen it was Jonathan Roden at
Stanford especially published some
things about the relationship between
population density and party vote chair
and Rodan stuff I thought was just
mind-blowing that that there's this
almost pretty tight almost linear
relationship between higher density
higher Democratic vote chair lower
density higher Republican vote chair you
know as you if you go to the densest
part of any town in the country and then
start walking towards the edge of town
it just gets the you know you if you're
at the middle of the town at the densest
part it's the most democratic part and
if you just kind of walk toward the
country
it just gets progressively less
democratic and then and then the less
dense it gets the less democratic it
gets the more Republican it gets that
struck me is crazy
like what how could that be the case and
then the second thing which is relates
to an interest that I've had for a long
time in political psychology my my grad
study so I was a PhD student in
philosophy and I studied stuff at the
intersection of political philosophy and
cognitive science and I have long been
interested in you know what explains why
people have the moral temperaments
dispositions that they do why people
have the kind of political impulses that
they have so I was aware of all of these
literature's that correlate personality
types to you know different political
attitudes and and and so I was looking
at those pictures of the relationship
between population density and party
vote share and just kind of mapping that
on to what I knew about the relationship
between partisan loyalty and kind of
left-right ideology and personality and
I was thinking well if both of those
things are true this means that that
there has to be that that gradation
along density from
less democratic to more Republican has
to be a gradation in terms of
personality as well like that and I was
like could that be the case now I got
really interested in that and and in the
paper started to take shape out of that
like how did we get this kind of
division in in our politics it seems to
you know reflect a real division in you
know real spatial division in where left
and right leaning kind of people end up
living let me pause for a second to talk
about the great courses plus we all know
that college or university has good
parts and bad parts the bad parts might
be you know doing homework or paying
your student loans the good parts are
the best lectures the best courses that
you took so what if you could have just
the good parts that's basically what the
great courses plus is it's a streaming
service or there's also a great courses
Plus app so you can listen to and watch
some of the best lectures and some of
the most interesting topics you've ever
heard from the best teachers all around
the world at major universities Harvard
Yale Stanford I personally have done
three different courses with the great
courses you can check out my course on
dark matter and dark energy the dark
side of the universe and right now for
mindscape listeners there's a special
limited time offer a free month of
unlimited access to the entire great
courses plus library to get this offer
you can sign up now through this special
URL go to the great courses plus comm
slash mindscape remember all the words
there that's the great courses plus.com
slash mindscape start learning today
yeah the personality stuff I think is
especially fascinating in fact listening
I listen to your paper I listened to the
fact you know you did a an audiobook
reading of it which I thought was
fantastic because now if you ever have a
viral tweet you can actually say you
know go to my soundcloud and listen
my paper but also eating it induced me
even to take the big five test online so
we can talk about that great later on
but but before we get I can guess you
shine like a Bedouins there's so much I
do that when we get let me get to there
I want you to guess me because I guess
myself four out of five I would say but
but let's just emphasize the size of the
effect that we're talking about here
because it really is remarkable before
we get to explaining it you know you a
pithy summary is that you say in the
paper there are no Republican cities
which you know when you put it that way
sounds kind of dramatic and not only
that but it didn't used to be the case
right I mean this is a relatively recent
phenomenon but it's extremely strong now
yeah it didn't used to be the case I
mean so in the in the in the paper I go
through like three different mechanisms
of sorting I mean maybe I should back up
a second and just you know just mention
the the overarching context of of
urbanization the
that is one of the things that I felt
was being overlooked in a lot of
explanations that I was seeing for just
a lot of Social development's broadly
like if you look at it like urbanization
is clearly the most momentous thing
that's happened in human social life
over the past 200 years is this just
absolutely immense transformative force
the entire human population has
basically filtered itself out from you
know we used to be really diffusely
spread out over the territory we when we
had agricultural economies that
sprinkles people around in a you know
relatively uniform sorta way but the end
of the agricultural economy the
beginning of industrialization Lyanna
led to this slow shift of the population
towards these big concentrated you know
hubs of commerce and trade and and in
that is a worldwide phenomenon it's just
absolutely immense and you know it's a
you know a lot of people don't realize
how big the effect is like like in 1790
when the Constitution was written and
New York City had like 33,000 people in
it yeah and and you know that's about
the size of my hometown which I talk
about in my paper in Marshalltown Iowa
which is you know just a bit less than
30,000 but now we have you know just
scores of cities that are over you know
metro areas that are over a million
people and all over the world just
populations are continuing to
concentrate more and more and more and
that fact has to really mean something
right like that that that's gonna make a
difference to the way people are
relating to each other and then thinking
about that one of the things that
immediately came to mind was Thomas
Schelling's work on on segregation which
may or may not be familiar to I wrote
about it in my book the big picture and
you did
that's awesome would you want do you
want to explain it because I don't know
no this is this is why we're here for
you to explain it but it you know it's a
it's a way of explaining segregation
even when people have only mildly Pro be
by my own in-group kind of attitudes
right yeah exactly like so shelling and
if you've you know he's a big influence
on me I I love Thomas Schelling he's a
economist at Harvard he won the Nobel
Prize for his work in game theory and
he's got this terrific book called micro
motives in macro behavior is that what
it's called and you know and in the
whole point of the books to show how you
get you know aggregate effects out of
you know individual choices and he's got
a very very simple elegant model where
you you can do the you
do it on the checkerboard if you want
like you can take the white pieces and
the black pieces and just distribute
them on squares randomly and the rule is
that each of the pieces wants to you
know we're imagining each of the squares
as like a house and and and so there are
eight squares that touch any square
unless it's at the edge right you know
the up-down left-right and both
diagonals and and and the constraint is
everybody you know nobody minds being in
the minority it's fine to be in the
minority
you just want three of those eight
squares to be the same type you know
white or black as you and and so what
you have to do is you to move each piece
until it satisfies that constraint but
so you do it over and over again because
if you move one then it opens up a new
space and it violates the condition for
some other piece and as you get them all
situated you find that you've like
pretty radically segregated the board
right and so even this mild um
preference for you know homophily as the
social scientists call a homophily is
just you know liking sameness and that
seems to be a pretty deep feature of
human psychology that we everybody likes
people like them um our you know our
friends tend to be people like us you
know people you know it's even it's
interesting like people's friends even
tend to be like the same height they are
and stuff like that see home awfully in
all sorts of different different things
and and so that's an assumption of
yesterday uniform we come awfully and it
Nicholas Christakis on a previous
podcast and he labels it mild in group
preference mild in-group bias or
something like that one of yeah
something that he says just appears all
over the place in the animal kingdom
whenever social structures become to
exist at all yeah absolutely and so if
you look at shell experiment which which
it was just his little model and and
tons of people have done all sorts of
elaborations on this and you can watch
them on YouTube but like people you can
set up a population of of millions of
reds and blues or whatever you want them
to be and you can change the constraints
but like if you use shellings
assumptions you know it can take you
know if you've got a huge population it
can take millions of rounds but over
time those populations segregate fairly
cleanly like it like million or not just
like in half but you'll get these very
clear clusters of reds and blues that
are sharply demarcated from one another
but those are those assumptions again
are weak that's weak in group reference
and in in you can change those
assumptions and you can say like well
suppose the whites and the blacks on
your checkerboard have slightly
different preferences and one of them
has stronger ingre preferences than the
other and you can mess around with it
and you'll get even sharper segregation
and and and I was thinking about that in
the context of this massive you know
glacial shift of populations from the
country to the city like if there is
even small differences so this is and
this is what I think shelling is telling
you like it like like like you know even
if everybody's the same in terms of
wanting to be near members of their
in-group
if there's you know differences in the
nature of those groups can can make a
big difference so this is one of the
first cut my paper on in terms of what
of what predicts urbanization is just
ethnicity so almost the entire non-white
population has sorted itself into cities
it's it's and that is explained largely
by in-group reference you know everybody
likes to be around people like them and
especially if you were a minority who
has who is discriminated against who has
an ik who has a history of
of of oppression right like you're gonna
want some safety in numbers and and and
so you're gonna have to coordinate on a
place to be if you just scatter a
minority around the territory of a
country at random they're gonna be
isolated and that's scary right so they
tend to gravitate toward cities pretty
much any minority and it doesn't have to
be an ethnic minority you know gays and
lesbians are very very heavily
concentrated in cities and other kinds
of minorities are as well and and you
know there's a lot of reasons for that
but it's a clear thing that you see and
it's not that that african-americans or
Hispanics or Asians are or have more
in-group bias than anybody else is that
you know they're the same on average but
in order to satisfy even a weak
preference for being around people like
them they're all going to have to
basically go to the same place if there
are fewer of them yeah that's the other
few of them there is no real option if
you're a person of color you might
prefer to live in a rural place a
low-density place but there's no way to
satisfy the preference of being around
people like you and living in a rural
place for the most part if you're an
ethnic minority so you have to give up
on one of those two things and most
people who would have um you know whose
residential preferences lean more in the
direction of low density if they're an
ethnic minority they just generally give
up on living in the country and end up
living you know in a slightly pastoral
suburb or something like that it away in
a place it's close enough to other
members of their of their of their group
but White's the white majority in the
United States has it's easy if you if
you really like to live around other
white people and you don't like urban
density Buren's you're in luck if you
can live basically
anywhere that's not a city is almost
entirely white and and that is you know
kind of the crux of a lot of the the
thinking in my paper where I'm just like
so are there difference because one of
the things that then you're starting so
if you if you you know first past is
ethnicity non-white ethnicities soared
into City some white people sort into
cities but others don't and if you're
and if you're trying to explain why the
Republican Party is the way it is and
the Republican Party is almost entirely
composed of white people who haven't
sorted in cities then there's an
interesting question about if there are
systematic differences between the white
people who sorted in cities and the
white people who didn't but also before
we get there
there is this issue of sorting in the
sense of picking up and going somewhere
versus just choosing up to leave right I
mean how many of the white people who
are outside the city started inside the
city and said nope this is not for me
I'm gonna move out to the country you
know I don't know the number but it's
surpassingly small just given the
overall trend of urbanization so yeah
just a huge percentage of moves are
toward higher density and that's one of
the most important facts about
urbanization that means that almost all
mobility is from lower to higher density
it's it's not always the case I mean did
there's there's been a big shift of
populations within big urban areas where
where where suburbs gain are gaining
population faster than the denser cores
and some of that is because of housing
prices and and some men and I'm part of
what it means is you know that a lot of
people but there are a lot of people are
getting priced out of urban cores I'm
moving from higher density to slightly
lower density suburbs but those suburbs
are still urban all right yeah
and so there's not a lot of movement so
there's some movement from high
lower density but there's very very
little movement overall in the aggregate
from metro areas to rural areas or from
from you know from the city from the
core of a city to you know add the the
fringe excerpts you just don't see a lot
of that there are places like rural
places that are gaining population a lot
of them are people who are from cities
moving to the country that but they tend
to be you know in the recreational rural
category like the people who are buying
a country home or you know you you're
moving to a ski resort or you love to
hike and mountain bike and so you move
out into the you know to some you know
nice spot
you know outside Boulder or something
like that so there's some rural growth
in those areas that involve people
moving from cities to those places but
the overly speaking yeah we have you
know sort of whites who want to be in
the city moving to the city and
minorities also moving to the city and
then whites who don't want to be in the
city just staying put where they are
yeah so there's a lot of staying put but
then there's also that the the the trend
of urbanization is so strong that that
still there's a lot of movement in any
case right but but where you stop is
gonna reflect these differences among
individuals that determine what kind of
place they like to live in so the
incentive to urbanize are so strong that
even people who are resistant to cities
or you know still they're gonna you're
gonna earn more in a city the the if you
want to capitalize on the wage bonus to
higher education it's hard to do if you
don't move to a large labor market so
you know I I live in Iowa most of the
time my wife is a professor at the
University of Iowa and there's a lot of
students here um you know like I grew up
in a smaller town in Iowa and if you
wanna if you go to a public university
and you get a bachelor's degree and you
to benefit economically from the from
that training and that increase in your
skills you just can't go back to your my
can't go back to Marshalltown Iowa and
make what I make as a think-tank vice
president in Washington DC like I can't
like I'm lucky that I can also live in
Iowa City Iowa
but like the sorry I think this is worth
digging into a little bit also because
you know I grew up in the 70s and 80s
where cities were just thought of as you
know vast oceans of poverty and crime
and it's still correct me if I'm wrong
but cities still have a lot of poverty
in them not just rural areas but there's
a lot more inequality in cities right
there's very wealthy people there's a
healthy middle class and there's poor
people in cities whereas there's a
little bit more homogeneity in the rural
areas and it's homogeneity at an overall
level of lower income than you might
find in a city is that a fair if rough
oh yeah absolutely there are cities have
a massive amount of inequality but it's
that's where poverty is very heavily
concentrated and there are a lot of
reasons for that
Edie Glaser has some great stuff on why
cities are better for poor people and
why they're particularly attractive if
you have less money yeah but cities are
increasingly productive as you're some
of the podcasts that you've done there
are these efficiencies increasing
efficiencies from the population density
from agglomeration as the economists
call it and and that is increasing the
wage bonus to urbanization so that
you've got these two things happening at
once you've got a you've got a wage
bonus from higher education that's
increasing because of technological
change as technology changes it doesn't
affect everybody's productivity equally
you need to have a higher and higher
level of education to have your
productivity amplified by the
communication and information technology
so so the you know the and we aren't
educating people fast enough to keep up
with demand so there's a a rising bonus
to getting higher education and higher
levels of education and that is
amplified by this independent not not
independent but but but a but related
thing that's happening in cities where
where there's something about the
knowledge economy and the information
economy Paul Romer the economist has
another Nobel Prize winners done great
work on how how growth is increasingly a
function of just coming up with new
ideas the ideas drive growth you you and
and that idea production really seems to
be higher when you concentrate a lot of
really really smart people together like
you're you know you're a professor at
you know what are the world's great
universities and you know that it's kind
of obvious when you're at you know a
Caltech or something like that that
you're more productive they're they
don't worry you know somewhere else
because you have all these incredibly
smart people that you interact with
every day and that levels you up you
know it's like I like to play pick-up
basketball and and do you become a
better basketball player if you play
with better players right like like and
that's just what it is for a large part
there's so there's two aspects of that
increase in productivity from from
concentration is that you know if you're
a coder and you are around other great
coders you learn a lot from them and
there's a kind of competitive pressure
that pushes your level up but that's not
where most growth come from comes from
most growth doesn't come from just these
marginal increases in individual
productivity it comes from these bigger
ideas that lead to innovations that that
that increase productivity in a way the
scales across a huge port parts of the
population and so those ideas tend to
get produced more quickly when you get
smart people together you know kind of
shooting the breeze
and so there's a you know increasing
concentration of economic production in
cities and that makes them as I say in
the paper more magnetic right like the a
good way to think about urbanization is
that that over time cities you know
cities are like magnets and the
incentives to urbanization are like the
you know level of magnetic attraction
and it keeps being you know it's like an
electromagnet you keep turning it up and
you know it keeps getting the the pull
keeps getting stronger and stronger and
as that cluster of people gets bigger
and bigger it turns up the magnet again
and again and again and which is why pop
the whole population is filtering toward
toward the cities unless you know you
were you know not very magnetic kind of
person like oh you're like as I say the
paper like you know if you if you
imagined it is ball bearings just
distributed on the table with a magnet
in the middle and the ball bearings are
made out all sorts of different metals
all the magnetic metals are gonna get
drawn toward the towards up the magnet
eventually in a but if you know you're
aluminum or a plastic ball bearing or
something you're just gonna you know
basically sit where you were the entire
time and I think there's something like
that going on in in the way urbanization
has been working some of us are less
magnetic than others and so despite this
very strong just dynamic this is
happening drawing millions and millions
of people towards cities some people are
just less likely to filter in and and my
conjecture which i think there is some
basis in is that is that the things that
make people less likely to urbanize are
also things that predict more
right-leaning political views we're very
fond of the physics based analogies here
on the mindscape podcast we approve of
that but but yeah so that's what we want
to get into the other this there's
urbanization of fact and it affects the
environment and it affects the knowledge
economy and everything
but it also sorts its right it doesn't
affect everyone equally and political
leanings are one of those but maybe the
you also talk a lot about personality
types in the big five and is maybe
causally that comes before the political
leaning yeah I think so I mean there's
there's there's controversy about the
extent to which you know personality is
a independent variable you know in
extent which is sort of exogenous of
people's political opinions right so the
question is you know maybe this is
moving to a city make you a more liberal
personality type as living in the
country make you more conservative and
implore education right or education
so that's or the trait of the among the
big five that that are that are most
politically relevant are openness to
experience and conscientiousness these
predict whether you're more liberal or
conservative in your social views but
all five of them are because we might
not know a good mnemonic is ocean
openness to experience conscientiousness
extraversion agreeableness and
neuroticism neuroticism is often called
emotional stability if you kind of flip
the sign of it and and most of those
have no relationship to political views
but openness and conscientiousness have
pretty significant relationships I guess
with my you want to guess what my
results were you are well so all
academics are relatively high openness
girl here yeah you're high openness
you've got a podcast about exciting
ideas and you know that illustrates what
openness is so openness is you know is
curiosity is a large part of it it's a
it's a large you know it involves
just interest in new things yes so if
you're high and openness you're more
interested in reading the new novel
you're interested in the cool new movie
you're interested in traveling to places
you haven't been before and encountering
other cultures encountering people who
aren't like you you're interested in
trying new cuisines things like that and
that correlates that's the strongest
correlate of liberalism or conservative
Oh highly high openness people tend to
be more liberal lower openness and
people tend to be more conservative the
other the other trait that has a
significant relationship is
conscientiousness and consciousness is
the is the you know getting it done a
personality trait it's a you know highly
conscious people like keep lists I you
know meet deadlines they just generally
have their their [ __ ] together right
like that's that that's that's what
conscientiousness is and but it's
research might not be clear how that how
that relates politically high
consciousness people tend to be more
conservative low conscientiousness
people tend to be more liberal the
conservatism of conscientiousness is is
involved in one thing that the
conscientious people really dislike is
uncertainty there's a strong conscious
people want there to be a clear
relationship between effort reward or
inputs and outputs right like in and
it's like it's it's it's the a student
personality trade you know it's a
Hermione Granger yep like you you want
to know what you need to do to get the
thing yeah
and so like what do I have to do to get
the grade so like the content you're
conscientious students are the ones who
like bad you after class about what
exactly the syllabus means you know
because they gotten too old to be just
yeah yeah and and in and in low
conscientiousness people like me
it's like you don't keep lists and and
and and like yeah and just are amazed if
they ever make a deadline you know like
have are much more tolerant of this kind
of uncertainty and in flexibility and so
there's there's an inflexibility in
conscientiousness and there's a has to
be a slight fear of just a strong desire
for stability just want to know how
everything works so they can hit their
marks I was I was very low on
neuroticism and completely middle of the
road on conscientiousness extraversion
and agreeableness but it's interesting
to me this you know both conservatives
and liberals get one good quality that
they correlate strongly with right
because most people would probably say
being conscientious is good being open
is good that's that's the sort of normal
valence that those terms have but is
there I take it that because they're
supposed to be useful dimensions in five
dimensional personality space there
there must be people who are high
conscientiousness and high openness and
low in each right and and they don't
have an obvious place to fit absolutely
yeah like the the the way these traits
emerge I mean you know like it's not
exactly the real things but you know but
the the traits come out of like a factor
analysis where you're trying to figure
out the minimal set of traits that don't
correlate very strongly with one another
right so observing the whole idea is
that they're independent of each other
and so higher you know openness and
conscientiousness just swing completely
freely of of one another
alike so that they like the academic
personality type is very high openness
and relatively high conscientiousness
like like academics tend to be a
student's really like you know it's hard
to become a professor if you know to get
through that much school if you can't
turn papers in on time and low
consciousness people struggle with that
but conscientiousness is the best trait
to have in terms of predicting success
in school and in your career so higher
cheston's people are more likely finish
school they're more likely to more
likely to finish anything
if they start it and yeah high
conscientiousness predicts higher
salaries people high heavy conscientious
people tend to be a little more
productive this doesn't make you want to
do anything right like it's like it's
it's it's a kind of auxilary or kind of
workhorse trait like openness has more
motivational Drive to it like so if
you're high openness it makes you
attracted to certain kinds of thing so
consciousness is the trait that makes
you good at school openness to the trait
that makes you want to learn right um
and and and and those are you know and
those are relatively independent of one
another you know one of the SATA there's
a sad finding that I reported the paper
from Shelley Lundberg labor economist at
Santa Barbara thing and a which is that
you know generally conscientiousness
predicts academic performance but it
actually doesn't for for lower
socioeconomic status students like like
you'd want to think that the the the
working hard and getting stuff done
dimension would predict academic success
for for less wealthy black students for
example but it doesn't but turns out
that openness does right like and and I
think that that's a good example we're
seeing that the motivational aspect of
openness that that that if somebody's
less privileged and they've got a lot
that the deck is stacked against them
the thing that really pulls you through
is just the desire to learn I'm just I
am and so they so the so these traits
they're interested and one of the things
that one of the reasons why I fixed on
the big five as opposed there are other
kind of personality theories that that
that are specifically intended to
explain political views and moral views
like Jonathan heights
moral foundations theory but some of
those are a little bit problematic it's
hard to it's hard sometimes the it's
it's not so clear that the you know that
if that if I identify as a conservative
that that doesn't just affect my answers
on the yeah you know the oral
foundations quiz but the big five isn't
intended to explain your politics and it
explains lots of other things and this
Ben replicates really really well and
you know helps explain all manner of
behavior and that's one of the things
that I found interesting about it so
like like because high openness
you know explains but like light you
know will weekly predicts your
inclination to go to college at all even
though it doesn't mean that you'll be
good at it
it makes you want to go to school and if
you go to school and get a college
degree that that amps up your your
magnetic attraction to cities because
that's where you're gonna benefit from
your from your from your degree um but
and presumably even if not right I mean
the idea that if you did go up in a
rural environment the chances that you
would pick up stakes and move to a scary
diverse pluralistic urban environment
are probably much greater if you score
high on openness yeah absolutely so then
and that's one of the most important
aspects of the set of correlations that
openness and conscientiousness have with
with other stuff so both openness and
low openness and high conscientiousness
relate to a broad set of traits that you
could just call ethnocentrism or
in-group bias and so people who are
lower openness tend to be more
ethnocentric their degree of homophily
the strength of their their preferences
for sameness or stronger and so lower
openness people are more put off by
by difference and diversity and so if
you're lower openness that's gonna make
you less interested in and maybe averse
to places where there are a lot of
people who are unlike you and that's
very very interesting and especially
since as you know in the context of a of
someone like Donald Trump who's doing
everything he can to elicit people's
sense of you know that's know centric
solidarity so so the so higher openness
people as I said before are interested
in people who aren't like them they're
interested in other cultures they're
interested in other foods so if you're
higher and openness you're just gonna
find the urban diversity more attractive
and if you're low and openness you're
gonna find it unsettling so that's
important just in and of itself but then
secondarily and this is one of the
things that I found most important most
interesting is that like lower openness
also just predicts your inclination to
migrate at all yeah so higher openness
people and it makes sense when you start
just thinking about though you know the
how it relates to an interest in novelty
and difference lower openness people are
less likely to want to move and they're
less likely to actually move higher
openness people are you know way more
likely to want to go somewhere new
theirs which is one of the reasons what
higher openness people are you know
somewhat less yeah I want to be careful
about not making a sound like openness
is great and low openness is terrible
well because because low openness people
are just better friends their group they
stick to their group right like it like
it you like you like it yeah you're low
up and his friend is the guy who's gonna
show up at 3:00 in the morning bail you
out of jail
Yeah right like like if you were your
lowest openness kid
is the one who's gonna call you yeah
when you're old yeah yeah for you sure
guy yeah five to two anecdotes I know
this is not really systematic data but
it helps make all these points vivid to
me one was driving someone around an
older person who I'm sure would score
and low openess driving around my
neighborhood here in LA and seeing all
of these signs on the storefronts many
of which are in Spanish some of which
are in Asian languages and and they just
said you know doesn't that bother you
and I'm like no the food is much better
here because because of all this kind of
diversity we have but it just struck me
that I wouldn't even have thought that
that should bother me and on the other
side of the veil or my side you know I
knew a guy who had been in the army his
whole life and he retired and he
immediately got a job as a security
guard and explaining why he mentioned
the fact that he got to wear a uniform
every day and again that sort of never
would have occurred to me as a good
thing but I get it that it is a good
thing and it's I kind of don't like the
label openness for that reason it's it
sort of biases us towards instantly
thinking that openness is good but there
are absolutely values I think that I
think that having different restaurants
with different ethnicities is is an
unambiguous good thing but but I get the
idea that there are people who just want
to keep things simple uniform doing the
same thing every day so they have space
to worry about other things that's not
intrinsically personal failing no not at
all and in in and that is and I think so
so if if my overall hypothesis is right
in that in that overtime the higher
openness people are more likely to
migrate and therefore urbanized because
migration is mostly urbanizing migration
and lower openness people are going to
be more resistant to or less sensitive
to the incentives that drive people to
urbanize over time the less dense
populations the rural populations
should become lower and lower openness
um that like that that is kind of an
implication of the view and and and as
the magnetism of cities ramps up right
like it will tend to pick people off who
are on the margin right like they're you
know each of these traits is normally
distributed and so you know people who
are on the on the on the low tail of
openness or you know least likely
I mean I'm most likely to be routed to
put down stakes to be incredibly loyal
to their community to family to the
people around them they're not gonna
want to give up on that you know but
most people are in the middle you know I
my definition and you know and as you
kind of down the bell curve as the
magnetism of the of the city you know
ramps up starts picking people off you
know further and further down the bell
curve but that leaves the average in a
lot of these places in you know like
higher open like lower a nope yes and
and and and and and that will tend to
give an increasingly conservative
ethnocentric cast to a lot of these
places you know I wanted to mention that
that openness and conscious just predict
your predict social and liberal are
sorry social liberalism and social
conservatism things like abortion
same-sex marriage immigration attitudes
towards race but it doesn't relate at
all to economic views that's does it
that those don't relate in any
systematic way to any of the personality
stuff so it's just these just these
social views so if over time the sorting
dynamic of urbanization is leaving these
places increasingly low in openness
they're also getting higher in
ethnocentrism and then on top of that
you have the effects of the thing that's
driving people to the city or the first
place which is that that is where
economic production
increasingly happens so I draw heavily
in the paper on on work by and Rico
Moretti he's got talks about you know
the great divergence that there is this
real divergence in our economy between a
handful of extremely high productivity
cities and everywhere else you know
everywhere else includes a bunch of
other cities including like kind of Rust
Belt cities that are in decline not it's
not that all the places that are in
relative decline are not urban but
almost all the places that are on the
upswing are are urban and almost the
entire lower density parts of the
country are either stagnating
economically or or actually declining in
terms of economic welfare and so when
you add an increasingly low openness
high ethnocentric white population to
this economic stagnation you're gonna
get a lot of disgruntlement
a and and and those populations as well
are the the average level of education
is going down again because of the
overall magnetism of cities two highly
skilled highly educated people and and
that is basically the reason why that
you know that that's the kind of
first-order explanation for the great
divergence that the increasing wage
bonus to higher education and the
concentration of all the jobs where you
get that wage bonus at big cities has
filtered almost the entire highly
educated population out of the rest of
the country and that leaves these other
places at a permanently kind of like
lower level of productivity and I do
want to ask an economics question here
I've seen various graphs that seem
pretty convincing that after the 2008
recession there was a comeback but the
comeback went very strongly
people who are doing well in the first
place like the rich people are doing
fine after 2008 the middle class is
doing okay and almost none of the gains
went to people who were doing badly is
there is there sub structure there in
terms of rural versus urban you did
urban poor people come back more than
rural ones or vice versa
I'm not sure about the the poor
population specifically but-but-but-but
urban populations bounce back much okay
much quicker then then then rural
populations and that is a big part of
the story the that that those places
don't do well with you sure here's an
interesting you know like a sidebar
you know conscientious mist as I said is
that it's the individual trait that most
predicts just success in your career and
in conscientiousness also you know
conscientiousness doesn't make you less
likely to migrate but if you are but but
it makes you more resolute in in in
executing any preferences that you might
might actually have and so if you're low
if you're the most conservative profile
if you're low openness and high
conscientiousness you're gonna you know
really stick to stick to not going
anywhere and in in in so high higher
conscientiousness at the individual
level you know means that you're gonna
have a higher income but hiring
conscientiousness the population level
doesn't predict a higher level of
productivity and and and I think that
has to do with the fact that that the
that that that growth is an ideas thing
and and that it's also like has to do
with flexibility so there's a great
paper in about the UK in terms of
population level personality traits and
and the higher conscientiousness places
didn't bounce back from the recession as
fast as the higher openness places and
that seems to be because higher openness
people are like more flexible
they like to like how are we gonna deal
with this problem the conscientious is
high conscious just people are are the
ones who want to know what the rules are
right but if the rules change they
struggle and so high consciousness
people can take advantage of
opportunities but high openness people
are more likely to get the opportunities
or go out and actively get them yeah
there and they're also they're gonna be
the kind of people who explore the space
of possibility and see how to adapt to
the new situation so so the it's it's a
it's the creative personality type the
the you know the most creative profile
is is is mine as it happens like very
high openness very low conscientiousness
they it's associative and and and and
flexible but high conscientiousness low
openness is very well you know you just
want to do the done thing and if the
world changes around you it's just
incredibly confusing and I think it's
like super important not to be
judgmental about that it's it's that or
that's just how sit one of the things
that writing this paper is done for me
is it's actually made me feel more
empathetic toward Trump voters I like to
try to get inside what the mindset is of
you know lower openness higher
consciousness people like the changes
that our culture economy population is
going through are truly unsettling if
you have that kind of mindset like this
is a high openness thing trying to get
inside somebody else's head but like
paradox of openness yeah the paradox of
openness but but that's partly why
higher openness people are more have you
know higher racial sympathy for example
though they're more likely to be able to
understand what it might mean to be a
minority and have opportunities
systematically denied to you in these
kind of structural ways whereas low
openness people just don't get it but
they have a hard time understanding what
other people's experience just like
really interested yeah I mean just to
make this very clear I think that you
know the picture that you're painting
seems to come together in a view where
there's a set of people who live outside
the cities who are you know have been
legitimately really damaged by the
economy and at the same time and maybe
for related reasons are ones who are
naturally prone to be a little bit more
skeptical of minorities and change and
foreigners and immigrants and things
like that
and it comes together and and maybe this
argument we had over why Trump won after
he won was it because of economic
anxiety or because of racism or
nationalism you know these things are
all different aspects of the same
underlying causation exactly and that's
one of the things that I try to draw out
that they're not really two separate
explanations there's this big macro
economic fact which which urbanization
really is it's it's it's it has to do
with the changing structure of the
economy and the incentives that that
gives people to resettle and that has
these strong effects on who gets the
benefits of economic growth and and if
this dynamic is filtering the population
in a way that leaves lower density
populations basically more social
increasingly socially conservative but
also depriving them of the benefits of
of growth it's not it's not happening
where they live and they're not getting
the full benefit of it that puts those
people in a position where it becomes
very easy to sell them a narrative about
why things seem so bad to them so if
somebody like Trump comes along and says
things are going shitty for you I'm
gonna make America great again which
means make America
it was when you felt comfortable or like
you thought it was would you feel
comfortable yes yeah or yeah exactly
like your you're sort of nostalgic
fantasy about the past was like and the
thing that's causing all these problems
is all these immigrants and these you
know elites who live in cities who are
selling you out to the Chinese and
giving her jobs to Mexicans and so on
and so forth that you know the that kind
of person who is who lives in those
places is going to be very prone to find
that really persuasive and then the the
additional factor that I lay onto it so
like most of this explanation is the in
the overall story I'm telling is about
selection effects and that and and some
selection effects that have been I think
overlooked in the way that that
urbanization has has segregated the
population and that's sort of shelling
like way but there are these treatment
effects right like there there's this
large literature on how growth tends to
be liberalizing that that the further
you get from a sense of economic and
security basically the more tolerant and
open you are to difference and change
and the this is really really well
confirmed like like it feels to a lot of
us like there's a kind of one-way arrow
to kind of moral progress that's in a
liberalizing direction because economic
prosperity or rising economic prosperity
tends to make whole populations more
culturally liberal you you you get a
transition from you know ronald
englehardt is the is the big innovator
in this area from from what he calls
survival values to self expression
values but you don't get that in a
uniform way over an entire population
when growth is in
creasing Lee economically concentrated
in cities so all of the already more
liberal people in cities are
experiencing the benefits of growth
which tends to make those populations
even more liberal right and so which in
its so a good example of that is is is
you know the change in you know just
even the past few years towards
transgender people and the norms around
it right like like so that rapid shift
in norms about acceptance of transgender
people like like how important it is to
use people's preferred pronouns to
acknowledge their preferred gender
identity that that is that that's
textbook increase in self expression
values but the kind of growth that makes
people you know have you know increasing
self expression values if that's not
going to these already more conservative
lower openness populations then then
you're getting even further polarization
in terms of culture and values right so
to that population who's not
experiencing the same increase in
prosperity and they're already more
conservative they they hear talk about
like using somebody's preferred pronoun
and they're like what the hell is even
happening like like there are two
they're like I get emails from all of
these conservative institutions and
they're just all going crazy right now
about like hella yeah we can't tell the
difference between a man and a woman and
and I think that is a is a really direct
effect of the joint filtering of the
population leaving the more leaving the
rural populations more conservative in
terms of disposition but also depriving
them of the kind of treatment effects of
growth that would make them a little bit
more liberal intolerant they're just not
getting it and so these the urban and
rural [ __ ]
cultures moral cultures and political
cultures are just growing further and
further apart and and to the extent
there there's a kind of backlash
I think it's driven by those combined
effects where it just seems literally
crazy to conservative people
conservative white people in small towns
to hear people talking about about you
just like choose your own gender it
seems like like it just seems absolutely
it seems like the whole world's upside
down but for us so what is gay then the
we haven't quite yet talked about the
role of education here because I think
this is like the final piece of the
puzzle right that you talk about in the
paper we you know we have this set of
people rural people low on openness
things are changing all around them
they've been left behind by the economy
those populations or you know people and
families from those regions might have
their perspectives shifted if they got
more education is that but I never know
what the causality is is it just the
people who were more open in the first
place tend to go to college or people
who go to college become a little more
open it's it's it's very clearly both so
I so that the personality stuff is you
know it's it's it's not fixed the
openness say is about the heritability
goes at about 60% you know like the the
the the variation that's explained by
genes is about that but there so that
that leaves a lot of room for for yeah
change for for differences that are that
are environmentally determined and it's
very clear that getting a college degree
makes you more open
buta traveling when you're young makes
you more open so going to college would
increase openness and does increase
social liberalism it but you know it's
also the case that if you're already
more open you're more likely to want to
go to college and and I think one thing
that people have overlooked which is
clear to me like having grown up in Iowa
and living at you know in Iowa City
where there are a bunch of students from
rural areas people overlooked especially
you know high openness urban people tend
to overlook the extent to which going to
college is a form of migration that is
uncomfortable to really rooted socially
you know temper mentally socially
conservative types you know going to
college means moving away from your
family it means moving away from your
friends
and and there's a huge attrition rate
you know from freshmen not coming back
for their sophomore year and I think
then some of it is just like it's it's
it's a bad fit and if you're from a
small Iowa rural town and you come to
the University of Iowa it's way more
diverse than any place you've ever been
it does it seems like a wild big-city to
you right um and and and in if those
rural populations are becoming more
conservative over time you're like I
think their parents are find it less
attractive to send their kids as well
like it is true that sending your kid to
college is gonna make them a little bit
more liberal but like it also means
sending them away from you you don't
want to do that like you love though
yeah you know you don't want them to go
away and you'd especially don't want
them to go away to a place that's gonna
make them even more different from you
and that if they get a college degree
they're gonna have to move even further
away from you
ed to this really scary big city that is
dangerous and full of weird languages
and smells and food like it like it's
just it's not appealing right like and
and and so I think some of the right
wing reaction against universities
currently has to do with some of this
just very deep-seated discomfort in and
in the you know that there's a there's a
feeling that somehow it's like left-wing
propaganda that is you know making their
children different from them but but you
know I think that's a you know a kind of
rationalization and the deeper thing but
also wanting to be separated from your
loved ones yeah in which I was gonna say
you know that's totally understandable
in some way I mean we do live in a
society where the idea that families
live together in the same neighborhood
over generations is more or less
disappearing and most of our population
right yeah absolutely
and and and and that's a real loss yeah
like like there's a real loss of
rootedness these lower openness places
tend to be higher
you know social capital kinds of places
like when people stick around they know
each other better
they are tend to be more deeply invested
in you know churches in in in you know
the Lions Club and the rotary and all
these civil society institutions those
places have a kind of like a rich
informal you know really tightly woven
together social life which is has a lot
of advantages it's a really nice way to
live if you fit that kind of place right
like it's suffocating for a certain kind
of person right um but everybody doesn't
have to live the same kind of life but
that kind of life is becoming less and
less feasible it's becoming less
economically feasible and and and it
feels if you're if you live in one of
those places it feels like the world is
trying to destroy everything that's
important to you and it's worth taking
that seriously yeah you briefly
mentioned churches but he didn't talk
about religion a lot in the paper is
that I mean it there's this even be
above urbanization there's just the
whole idea of modernization right and
the the strong attachments we have to
community to family to churches are
weakening with time and probably the
increasing secularization of the country
in the world is something that is both
significant and very bothersome to the
low openness people who are out there in
the rural districts yeah absolutely
I mean like the secularization is one of
those things that it but like it tends
to go along with rising self expression
values so so religious participation
tends to fall as you know GDP per capita
increases you know as people get born
more wealthy now what self expression
values mean is that you that that what
tends to dominate your interest is you
know being myself you know like like
finding the thing that fits rather they
la like
and you know in consumer culture is
really play into that and and that's not
really what the idea of religion is it's
like it's you know like yeah it's like
so people who are high in self
expression values are gonna be really
annoyed that the Catholic Church won't
change its views on first controller or
or or or on same-sex marriage right like
like you know you're like get with it
folks
but but like that's not what religions
are for what are the interesting things
about the United States is one of the
reasons it
I think maintains a higher level of
religious participation than a lot of
European countries is that it has this
history of really entrepreneurial
religious activity when I lived in
Houston for a couple years and there's
this guy oh what's his name Joel Osteen
yeah he's a big TV pastor and you know
he's got the old basketball Stadium as
his church if it's 15,000 people and I
went to it a couple times I'm just
fascinated by again another high
openness thing I want to see what the
low people do right and and they and you
know it's barely a religion I mean it's
it's like he said Jesus twice it's just
this prosperity gospel stuff yeah but
it's but it's all in so it's really
heavily customized to what a certain
kind of person wants to hear and that
keeps people coming to church right like
it's you know it's about how if you have
faith and and you know and and try to
look good you know you know like you buy
a car that's nicer than you can afford
and then God will help you afford it you
know yeah and and it's so like you know
but that keeps people going to church
right it's adaptive in a way that you
know Catholicism is in it but it also
just rinses the actual religious content
out of it I think that has a lot to do
with with evangelical support for Trump
it's it's a certain kind of person but
they're the they're the actual content
of their religious convictions is is it
you know evangelicalism is basically
American is
with a with a light mom Christian glass
on it yeah and and and it doesn't really
it's more political than it is religious
it's more about being against abortion
and being in favor of American
exceptionalism then it really is about
you know exemplifying the lessons of
Christ in your personal life activity
that's not a and I don't want to you
know paint with too broad a brush there
there you know deeply devoted
evangelicals who are who spent all their
time helping people in need but there's
there's just a but there's also just a
very vulgar self expressive version of
it that that isn't really about anything
other than the expression of a suite of
right-leaning
well you've seen were very weird bizarre
to outsiders that people whose
self-identity is so centered around
their Christianity and religiosity are
fervent supporters of Donald Trump for a
whole bunch of different reasons but I
mean mate so maybe the diagnosis is on
the table I wanted to sort of move on to
prescriptions in a couple ways unless
you think we've missed anything that you
wanted to say about the overall picture
you're painting no no I think we got
most of it yeah I mean I think that uh
there's two big things looming in my
mind here one is you make the point that
people like to do these maps of the
United States and who voted red and who
voted blue and especially if you do at
the county level the blue counties are
very very tiny and in a sense that's
because you're just painting by acreage
right yes it's absolutely true that most
of the acres most of the land area in
the United States voted for Donald Trump
but most of the people voted for Hillary
Clinton they also most of the people
voted for Democratic Senate candidates
but they didn't win and you make the
extra point that a vast majority of the
GDP voted for Hillary Clinton right
there's much greater economic
productivity in the in the blue
regions than there are in the red ones
but furthermore the trends are all in
the direction of increasing
representation for those blue areas in
various reasons so it paints a picture
where the Republican Party forget about
conservative versus liberal as
ideological designations but as an
institution the Republican Party is
taking advantage of certain not really
Democratic features of our Republican
government the Senate the Supreme Court
the electoral college but that can't go
on forever right and you know are we
facing at some point a tipping point as
we started talking the conversation
about a tipping point where the
Republican Party just collapses and you
know gets 30% of the vote chair and is
in the wilderness for 15 20 years
well we think a lot about that at the
Miss cannon center because one of our
big projects is trying to kind of
restore a a moderate elements to the
Republican Party you know the more that
cannot Rockefeller Republican type of
right type of moderation and and it does
seem extremely unstable but it's but
it's but I think we're at a really
dangerous moment as well
so as you said that like it's the you
know but a lot of people need to know
about the you know after the 2012
election and that you peeed did this
kind of analysis about what we need to
do to you know to win in the overall
consensus was that we need to just
increase non-white vote share and if we
can do that we can hang on with big
national majorities you know
indefinitely yeah there was a lot of
talk about you know how you know george
w bush got like 42 percent of the
Hispanic vote if the Republican Party
can do that consistently they're golden
because there is this baked in low
density bias in our entire electoral
system so if the if we have what
calling the density divided and the less
dense part of the density divided is
systematically advantaged by the overall
electoral structure of our system then
like you know they can win they don't
they don't need majorities to win they
just need to you know keep you know just
chipping away at Democratic non way vote
share and just by one or two points
every cycle and they can just win
forever right now that was the idea um
and you know in the whole party
apparatus bought into that and you know
that's why in the last you know election
you had you know Rubio Cruz all these
guys were in favor of you know
comprehensive immigration reform that
was part of this pivot but like that's
out of thing with a lot of the
Republican electoral base is and there
was a $20 billion on the ground that
Trump picked up that this you know
increasingly ethnocentric lower density
population who's you know experiencing
economic stagnation kind of cultural
vertigo like like they don't want more
emigration and and and so he just
doubled down on this kind of nativism
which has shrunk the the gops electoral
base so now it's almost exclusively
white it's almost exclusively eggs urban
and rural and they can't keep winning
with that coalition they that so they've
got two options which is either to do
what they're gonna do in 2012 and start
chipping into the Democrats and you know
advantage with non-white voters or they
can cheat as basically and and it looks
for all the world like there's a very
strong investment in in in cheating
everything that is
super dangerous and it's very very bad
news you know so you know everybody
knows about me the Russian and
interference in the election everybody
knows about how the GOP is doing nothing
about securing our elections at all how
you know there's the Supreme Court has
said that you know pretty radical
partisan gerrymandering is okay and and
so the GOP right now seems to be just
doubling down on winning elections with
a shrinking minority by disenfranchising
Democratic voters and just straight-up
cheating that it really threatens the
legitimacy of our democratic system in a
way that you know could be really
destabilizing yeah and I do think that
well yeah I mean we we actually didn't
talk as much as I wanted to about that
what I think of that as the paradox of
racism here you know in the sense that
it seems weird at face value to say that
it was increasing racism that caused the
white democratic candidate in 2016 to
lose even though the black Democratic
candidate won in 2004 and 2008 sorry
2008 2012 I mean why why would
increasing racism have more in effect
when both of the candidates were white
but there is a I think that there is an
explanation there maybe we could tease
that out a little bit well you know one
of the getting in the more political
alignment side one thing that's been
happening over the past 30 years like
like part of the this overall sorting
story is that the the parties have just
become better sorted on on a bunch of
stuff and there used to be a lot of
liberal Republicans and conservative
Democrats and and that's changed like
there very few of them anymore so all
the conservatives have gone into the
Republican Party all the Liberals have
gone into the demo
party but like one thing that's it's
really hard to get crossed to a highly
educated people who follow politics
closely is just how little most people
pay any attention to politics at all
and how how little people know and so
part party alignment is you know first
of all it's you know it's no but nobody
you know lays out all their views yeah
well here's my view on the minimum wage
here's my view on abortion here's my
view on blah blah blah and then oh let
me and then let me check which party
matches that better that's a hundred
percent not how it works like like how
it works is first you it's it's what
social identity is most salient to you
like and and that's more complicated for
white people because being in the
majority just being white isn't so
distinctive but it's you know but it's
pretty clear for other groups right like
I'm I'm I'm black I want to vote for the
party that's gonna protect me against
discrimination right and and so and and
you learn that that's the Democrats and
then you're a Democrat and then once
you're a Democrat then you adopt
democratic views about things you know
same on the other side right so so it's
you know it's come to be that you know
if you're a certain kind of white person
you're a Democrat and if certain kind of
white person you're a Republican but
like people pay so little attention and
this is like what I went from when the
most depressing findings is that they're
a big part of the flight of
working-class whites toward the
Republican Party really does seem to
have been caused by Barack Obama being
president just existing just existing a
black Democrat in the White House was a
clear enough signal for people who don't
generally tune in to communicate that Oh
Democrats are the party for black people
who are for civil rights
oh I'm not for that and and and so there
was a huge shift in
whites with lower levels of education
toward the Republican Party that really
does seem to be have been generated you
simply by the fact of the the clarity of
the cue that Obama's blackness sent but
that doesn't seem to explain people who
shifted from being Obama voters to being
Trump voters that's interesting it it it
doesn't but I think there's you see that
shift this thing these you see that
shift happening well before Trump and
and so if it was happening anyway
largely sparked by just reaction to
Obama's race and then you have Trump
eliciting these ethnocentric impulses
that are more common in that population
so they're you know part of the sorting
story is is it also involves D
unionization and so the so the close
connection between organized labor in
the Democratic Party you know locked a
lot of working-class people into the
Democratic Party like kind of
reflexively it's just part of their
identity I'm a member of afl-cio so I
vote Democratic but falling Union
participation just you know like falling
rates of union membership have weakened
those ties their party loyalties a you
know kind of sticky over generations
like if it's just the fact that your
parents are Republican makes you way
more likely to be Republican and if your
and if your dad was a steel worker who
was a you know staunch Union guy and
Democratic voter you're likely to
identify that way too but those but if
you're not a member of the Union and
that's culture is just fading away where
you live those those connections become
more and more tenuous and then those
people tend to start sorting more on
these other identities right like I'm a
white person I don't like urban liberals
I don't like you know uppity black
people in the White House like President
Obama
and and and and that kind of person if a
guy like Trump comes along and activates
really encourages any sort of
ethnocentric impulse that you might have
I think that can you know instigate you
know a further shift but I think it was
happening before him he just he just
heightened the dynamic yeah it's just a
little it is just a little weird to me
but okay let me do it let's just you
know put a conclusion on this thought
about the future of the Republican Party
because I think I totally would have
bought that strategy that you outlined
for you know Republicans in 2016 that if
we can just get some non-white people to
be in our party you know there are
african-americans Asians Latinos who are
low on openness strong social
conservatives pro-family
and a coalition of urban people of that
form rural whites and high education
high-income whites you just want tax
cuts that could potentially be a winning
party but that's not the direction they
went in but on the other hand we have a
system of government that really really
favors having two political parties with
almost equal chances of winning right so
either I mean putting aside the disaster
scenario where we just you know have a
some sort of nationalist coup and get
rid of our representative democracy
entirely I'm not I'm not quite seeing
how we're gonna reach that new
equilibrium where Republicans do start
reaching out in the post trump era and
to maintain actually 50 percent of the
demographic yeah I mean currently I mean
the the the they're kind of locked in
partly because the the way Trump has
remade the GOP like like what parties do
is is you know kind of determined by you
know like little signs called the the
the policy demanders in the coalition
and and at this point he's so
strengthened the nativist you know some
nationalist wing of the party that one
of the big demands of the party it
is keeping the party a party of rural
white people right like yeah like
there's an understanding that that that
making like that broadening the
coalition I'm bringing in a higher
percentage of non-white voters kind of
digging in to you know you know right
now the the divided geographically is
around you know a thousand people per
square mile right like like if the
Republicans just pushed in a little bit
you know inside the outer suburbs they
could pick up you know more than enough
to keep winning but that means picking
up some more higher education voters
means picking up more non-white voters
and and if you get those people in your
coalition then those people's demands
matter to and if what you want to do is
just shut down the borders and basically
you're interested in and in in in in
stopping demographic change like you're
not gonna be able to cater to those
voters right like you're they're not and
so you so you just you want to keep them
out because they're gonna get in the way
of what you want to do and so they're
just they're just kind of stuck and and
I think the only way they change at this
point is there needs to be a you know
catastrophic electoral defeat you know
so my fingers are crossed for just a
gigantic Democratic victory in 2020
because that will at least force the
party to consider whether it can keep
going as a ethno Nationalist Party of
rural white people and well you know
create some opportunities for for others
to come in and say hey like let's like
the idea that we had before was a good
idea and to you know who pushed toward
the moderation of the Republican Party
but like our did that the integrity of
the entire political system really
depends on there being a you know
responsible governing right like power
is bound to change hands over time
and you need two parties in a two-party
system that that will actually try to
govern instead of what the GOP under
Trump is trying to do which is basically
destroy the system to keep itself in
power
that's how places collapse into banana
republics and so it's really really
important that that they face a
electoral catastrophe in order to force
that change yeah I mean I couldn't agree
more I think I would love to be back in
a world where it was not obvious to me
to which party to vote for I would much
rather have a much healthier vibrant
opposition party even if I didn't vote
for them I want them to be good and it's
always hard to tell when you know a
party changes in one direction is that
the beginning of a trend that will last
toward the future or is it just the last
gasp of certain parts of the party so
we'll have to see it'll be very very
interesting as you say fingers crossed
the other thing I wanted to close on is
like you said when you did the research
for the paper it does make you more
empathetic with the rural voters who you
are trying to understand better and I'm
entirely even if they you know gave in
to some bad impulses with respect to
nationalism or ethnocentrism I'm
completely on board with the idea that
the system has failed them and the you
know the their economic situation is not
very good and their prospects are not
very good I don't think that Donald
Trump is fixing things very well but how
should we fix things I mean how can we
you know organize given the fact that
technology is changing the world very
rapidly that urbanization is happening
how can we you know make carve out space
for economic and social success for
people who just want to live in rural
environments and have a lifestyle more
or less similar to what their families
have had for the last couple generations
yeah I mean I think that's an incredibly
important question one of the perverse
things about the GOP currently is that
it has very very little interest in
actually aiding its own base I wrote a
piece for The Times a couple months ago
which which which showed the
relationship between like economic
stagnation and just Republican you know
areas that they're the Hamilton project
at the Brookings Institution did a study
on economic vitality and so they have an
economic vitality index and and the huge
majority of counties in the United
States that are you know way underwater
in terms of economic vitality or you
know staunchly Republican places they're
low density and a rural small town kind
of areas and but the Republican Party's
ideology it's got a free-market anti
welfare state ideology basically gets in
the way of them doing anything at all to
mitigate the slide that's going on
economically among their own voters
which does create a big opportunity for
for kind of populist Democrats I think
you know both Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren have their fingers on
the opportunity there they they really
see what it is and and the way you know
what needs to be done really is we need
to improve our social insurance system
we need to make sure that people have
access to health care the United States
what are the only countries in the world
in which like there are some you know
some major populations like though the
white population has declining life
expectancy and it there really is
genuine desperate economic insecurity in
a lot of places you know the the opioid
epidemic I think reflects a lot of the
and you know self-medication around the
anxiety of the loss of jobs the loss of
economic vitality and a lot of places
where people live so at mascara we have
a project called the struggling regions
initiative which is a whole slate of
policies that are intended to help you
know bolster
um largely lower densities rural areas
not just rural areas but have you know
places that are aren't doing so well
because you know it's only until very
recently that even the economics
profession has got its head around the
fact that that inequality is
increasingly a regional thing that that
that there's a big Geographic aspect to
the way our economy is changing and that
there's not going to be a way to just
you know we can't reverse the trends but
we can mitigate the damage through just
social assistance but there's also a lot
of things that we can do to improve the
atmosphere for development and growth in
in a lot of these more rural states that
we aren't currently doing so so there's
there's a lot of good ideas that can be
pursued but it's just really hard I mean
a lot of people are just gonna have to
recognize the fact that a lot of small
towns have no function they don't have a
reason to be the reason there are all of
these small towns you know here in Iowa
they're you know just kind of peppered
all throughout the countryside and that
has to do with the fact that
agricultural employment you know
required getting people into these
fields all over the place but IRA
cultural employment has collapsed right
and these little towns were hubs of of
Education you know where you could buy
milk at a store and housing but like
nobody needs jobs in those places
anymore there are no jobs less places
anymore
they're leaving there's just automated
you know combines plowing through the
fields there's very little need for
agricultural employment so there's
really the little need for these towns
at all and in those populations a lot of
them we just have to recognize that they
that there they are we have to basically
put them on life support but like people
are there there are older people in
these towns they're never coming back
and and they just need help
we just need to help man and make the
decline of these places as as
comfortable as we can while at the same
time trying to do our best to promote
development and the place places that
the people from those small towns are
moving to so like all the populations in
the more rural states like here in Iowa
you know Des Moines is doing really
really well you're here in Iowa City and
Cedar Rapids we're doing really really
well
Ames is doing really really well these
places with universities with big
medical centers they're these hubs of
employment and innovation activity there
could be a lot more done to promote the
health health and growth in these places
and to build these kind of mini
agglomerations that will be
self-sustaining over time but they do
need subsidy they need some they need a
boost from the government in order to
get on the track where they're going to
be appealing places for people to live
and anoint and you can staunch some of
the flow of your you know educated
population moving to other states if you
do have attractive places with good jobs
for them to work but there's a lot of
work that has to be done to make that
possible yeah we should have said this
earlier well we talked about
urbanization we're not talking about New
York and Los Angeles exclusively right
we places like Des Moines and Ames
absolutely count and that there's a huge
benefit in terms of cost of living to
living in places like this so there can
be a very vibrant and diverse set of
urban environments throughout the
country in some sort of future
equilibria yeah we need to do a lot we
can do a lot to build up these mid sized
cities they do have an economic function
they can be very very productive but the
way things are structured now it's we're
effectively subsidizing the trend of
hyper concentration in a few big cities
and and we don't need to be subsidizing
that in the way that we it
kind of strangely we've been the the in
moving in the other direction you know
there's a huge problem in terms of
housing costs in these big mega cities
and that actually mitigates the problem
of concentration a little bit that
effectively redirects people toward
smaller cities and that's so it's
actually you know helpful in an
unintended way but we pay a big economic
price for that workers are less
productive in these smaller secondary
hubs but there's a lot to be said for
making these smaller secondary hubs for
building them up to the point where the
difference in productivity isn't as
large as it is now so that people have a
bigger menu of options in terms of
urbanization you know it's a wonderful
corrective the whole conversation
because we we talk so much these days
about the internet and being online and
connectivity and forget about the fact
that where you physically live still has
a huge effect on how you live who you
talk to how you think about the world it
absolutely does and that's one of the
puzzles about kind of glom raishin
efficiencies because the technologies
that have increased the bonus to density
are also the technologies that make it
seem like you ought to be able to work
from ever anywhere I mean like I do work
in Washington DC from Iowa most of the
time that's possible technologically but
it turns out that that that it's hard I
mean like before we started we had a
technological problem right like it like
it's difficult communicate over these
distances even with with the technology
and as someone who works remotely I can
really feel it like like we're mammals
and we're a were hyper social mammals
and I'm by myself in my basement and I
feel lonely and disconnected from the
people that I work with and I you know
start to be like what am I even doing a
blah blah blah but when I'm in the
office in Washington DC I have this
sense of you know you know bond OB and
camaraderie and like hey let's do this
guy's
right like and there's just a real
effect of getting like mammals
physically close to each other and being
like you know
a team we're doing something and I just
don't think you can replicate it I don't
think we'll ever replicate it through
technology we can we can you know kind
of you know maybe asymptotic ly approach
it through virtual reality or whatever
you know low latency versions of you
know communications technologies but but
but I just don't you know like I don't
think there's any any replacement for
actually being able to touch somebody
and you know smell them subconsciously I
mean like you like like it's like we're
animals and and there's a there's an
impulse in a lot of the tech sector to
see us as more abstract and less
embodied than we really are and I think
it that actually leads people to make
serious mistakes in understanding how
economies actually work yeah all the
technology out there in the world does
not change the fact that we are mammals
here you're absolutely right all right
we'll bill concern thanks so much for
being on the podcast this is a fast day
there's great talking you Sean thanks so
much
[Music]
you
[Music]